think to also worry about Carolina on their
penalty kill as they scored four short-handed
gold players [Applause] scored Chris quider it's
a power play goal Rangers lead one- nothing and
the the Rangers coming out of their own Zone
caner leads away watch this pass unbelievable
hard backand pass here it comes again look at
it fires it all the way across oh prer has to
do is tap it in to the New Jersey Devils what
a start for the season faceof win by tro Fox
the bage head high and wide with a shot Panera
looking to play it fox has it the all the way
through Panera for the net off the post
then they think well we'll do something
else we've talked about paner and shooting
the puck more often that was a screen Fox
moves it to Zan Jad pressured there by Seth
Jarvis number 24 pan to crder try to find it
here's FOX NOW pan boy they were the power
play unit playing with such confidence the
Aaron that's blocked by slaven yeah they just
go from option to option so quickly whether
it's a deflection or the shot from zaban Jad or
paner moving to the middle Fox finds the lane
save by Anderson no rebound as we mentioned
only one in the last five games there 17 for
18 and remember Tony deand and mve again is
Jarvis and he scores Seth Jarvis with a beautiful
shot has tied it up each team with a power
play goal use their speed coming up the ice
and beautiful pass to Jarvis who's just breaking
in through the middle and is able to get right
past both Ranger defenseman and that quick shot
by Jarvis that shot goes high and wide around
the boards goodro tried to play it to be treor off
that's blocked in front a HIIT on goodro and Nate
has got a stick on goodro wondered why there was
no penalty n puts it in front couple of Saves by
shiskin the puck still alive the puck and then
that was followed by this chance coming up in
front and then eventually trouba is able to get
over there Second Chance opportunities he said
we have to get those things in the offensive
zone on goal on the turnaround shot by Jordan
Stall a save made by shurin and he holds the
puck we'll see how the Rangers rotate the
defense Bill Howley all of Fame defenseman
handles the defense for the Rangers Bren
Schneider the outlet for fighter behind him no
icing Bren Burns back to get it long pass tipped
ahead by bunting picked up and then shot stopped
by sh searching the rebound stayed out left leg
here's a bouncing Puck and Terra ban who's
been the hottest of all of Carolina players
there's a collision Jack try whose uncle
is Chris try the Rangers president general
manager brought in by Natures father Teddy
jury played in the league Rangers three on
to across and the save made by Anderson the
rebound missed by heed rder and zaban Jad on
with Miller and Schneider that pass blocked
by krider he gets to through it good feed
zaban in and they shot it high around the
boards and out of the Zone lead to Stefon
Nason he's picked up there by Schnider Play
Back by spetch toov to Brent Burns now fetch
to C save made by sherkin he made it save on
the rebound as he stop C Ki chance here's the
shot let's see did crrider get a little
bit of he did krider did a good job and
so katami didn't get everything on that shot
but this was a good save through a screen and
then back for is lindr avoids the hit attender
un stretched theof here's AO finds an open man
save just Durkin what a save Guston moving with
a pu Ryder's open in front and Aon shoot save
by Anderson the rebound to the boards clear
out again as soon as they get it the defense
for Carolina spread out and cder's got room on
both sides P nice move it was tro on that move
tro shoots saved by Anderson able to see that
but this one's a better save bang bang quick
passing the shot and Anderson read that one well
goal tending on both sides has been good Rangers
were out shot 9 to four in the second period
they're out shooting in Carolina 85 here in the
third tough defensive play by Brady Shay on Blake
wheeler stopped his rush trouba trying to keep it
alive D'Angelo swept it away trouba in half it
again cers and he score will Coy great play by
Jacob trba to set him up two to one Rangers and it
hasn't happened often but wheeler gets in causes a
problem trouba makes this strong play pass two
players and then has the patience to wait for
kie to get the open what a play from trouba and
then the finish by the [Applause] kid ly G against
Jarvis that's deflected in front scramble
on just stetch and try to cover it he does
yeah fov was right there now he
and tro having a few words former
teammates a simple dump in and Carolina
goes to work and Jarvis just throws it
in front you'll see it bounce off a couple
of players and just sturken was alert there
you see snov trying to reach in and plays
it to the boards he's checked by Miller
Miller goes forward moves it stopped by Smet
toov tried to Cent her shot one wide oh big
setup for NES that shot stopped rebound
NES and shurin may have gotten a piece
of that shot by by nes protect the two to
one lead look at this save he got here's
NES out up top AO with the setup the Ango
shot is saved by shkin would have been a
little closer than that would have had it and
then D'Angelo with the last shot and out of the
Zone intercepted T good row empty net no it hit
the side of the net final seconds 3 2 1 Rangers
win